I was riding a Citi bike the other day
and someone screamed dr. Mike we want
more house m.d. here we go house m.d.
number three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you are are they both gonna be
patients in this episode reading Wow
that's a lot of blood a little poker dr.
Cuddy got one of your patients in the ER
be in Austin six years old oh I know and
what's the problem I'm all-in
bloody diarrhea hemodynamically stable
but he's been developing some
coordination problems
sounds like gastroenteritis and
dehydration order fluids and I'll take
it on mr. Betts to you house they scan
his head no why would they scale play
games you got a call how's the heart
rate stable I'm sorry
house it's gastroenteritis I'm not going
anywhere put the order in and if someone
talented Sara that I'll be up when I'm
done I hope that's a non-alcoholic
beverage in her hand if you're on call
and you're gonna be admitting patients
to your service you probably shouldn't
be drinking alcohol just saying don't
cold Bluff you might want to spend a
little more time paying attention to
your cards and a little next time stand
up my breasts they don't match either I
used to play poker semi professionally
during my college days I would play
online before it was banned and I would
make some money not a lot of money it
was more about a learning experience but
the friends that I played with we
constantly used poker as an analogy for
everything we did in life whether it was
medicine talking to girls and
relationships with our friends we would
always somehow relate it back to poker
and I feel like that's what's gonna
happen in this episode everything that's
gonna happen with this patient is
somehow gonna turn into a poker hand
what's interesting about poker is that
it's a lot like life making a difficult
decision you're not always gonna have
all your information available at your
disposal right because life is crazy and
things change all the time there's
variables so there's a lot of luck
involved in life that's the same thing
that happens in poker skill can only
take you so far there's a huge luck
component if your opponent has only one
card that will beat you despite the fact
that every other card is gonna work in
your favor they may win and if they win
it doesn't mean that they outplayed you
means that they got lucky the same
that can happen in life you can make a
great decision with all the information
available at your disposal and yet you
could still lose or have a bad outcome
follow my finger with your eyes
nystagmus
how much longer will dr. Cuddy be given
the number of mojitos she's knocking
back at the party counts it's gonna be
at least three hours before she's even
conscious weren't you at the same party
I don't drink I just pop pills I just
reach out grab my cane what's wrong
abnormals brain is in descent control of
his muscles dr. Cuddy's message said it
was just dehydration from the diarrhea
she's wrong I love house but the way he
jumps to knowing that there's something
more sinister happening with this child
from hearing the basic story little
extra some children when they have
diarrhea especially bloody diarrhea with
stable vital signs stable labs can act a
little bit strange and as time goes on
they improve by him
taking a special interest in the story
just from hearing that story it's a
little unrealistic two cases
same symptoms what does six-year-olds
and seven year olds have in common
this kid doesn't have kidney failure you
will I was treating a 73 year old woman
who went through this progression of
symptoms the last of which was in case
you missed that class in med school that
one's not treatable do a colonoscopy and
a six-year-old cutie pie is nothing
worse than some food poisoning if you
happen to find any purple papules do me
a favor and grab a slice I want to check
for a dime Chester how does he know what
that is I've never even heard of it I
don't know how you justify doing a
colonoscopy on a child with a single
episode of bloody diarrhea and a
stomachache with normal vital signs
normal labs just off of the fear that
there could be a rare potentially
life-threatening condition that hasn't
yet presented itself in any other way
outside of a taxi and bloody diarrhea
doing a colonoscopy while it's a common
procedure it's not a benign procedure
things can go wrong you can
the colon you can have an infection I
mean if something negative happens as a
result of the colonoscopy and you find
nothing that's horrible
you did that to the child you know how
people see the Virgin Mary in danishes
and stuff someone died 12 years ago and
house doesn't know why Kyle sees that
case now paint peeling in two hours I
agree with him and yes like I said
before residents don't do all the
procedures you would get a
gastroenterologist to do the colonoscopy
internal medicine residents don't just
do colonoscopies on their own this is
crazy why am I getting so upset about
this it's just a show chase is negative
for erdheim chester let me see Silla
know what that is
[Music]
it's not every time Chester it's exactly
what we said before garden-variety viral
gastroenteritis coming out back to the
party
don't kidney biopsy what's subjecting a
child to this many procedures that are
not benign on a whim is crazy there's no
proof that this is what's happening you
have to monitor the child watch the
symptoms act clinically ego check it
colonoscopy was claimed and the biopsy
was negative for erdheim chester so he's
gonna be alright it was just some sort
of virus what's that urine
no but it's brown means kidneys are
shutting down still think it's not the
same case now you can start thinking
that it's something else doctor has had
a patient a while back who exhibits as
symptoms as your son then you know
what's wrong no so what do you know we
know the likely course the disease will
take which is she had multiple system
failure what happened to her she died 24
hours after her admission look telling
patients information once you know what
is really important because you want to
honor the idea of autonomy where a
patient has the ability to act upon
their own body with the best information
possible in this case it would be the
patient's parents cuz the child can't
make decisions for himself however if
you have incomplete information and that
information is very worrisome and it's
not gonna bring any value to the
patients and only gonna bring anxiety
maybe best leave that information out
until you have a more concrete plan or
answer otherwise we're just creating a
lot of anxiety a lot of worry and
essentially telling these parents your
child might die today because we don't
know what we're doing the base of his
brain has been infiltrated by a small
mess we think to Atari looks that way
explains a low blood pressure you might
confirm the lymphoma
started Esther on prednisone did anyone
see the lymphoma no we saw a mess the
location was consistently CNE in the
blood either white blood cell shown is
spindling or abnormal nuclei nothing on
immuno chemistries either it's not
lymphoma
is having an anaphylactic reactions or
something and this throat's closing up
look at the right eye trim that's not
Kurosaki's no it's small but it's there
Esther didn't have a mass in our
Hartmann he is younger take more of a
pounding Esther died before the disease
reached her heart the disease made it
mass and made it fast could be bacteria
the muscle connective tissue the kid
can't take any more theories only thing
we know is that whatever that mass is
that's what he's got we need a piece of
it I'm doing a biopsy you gonna do a
biopsy the kids hard come on house out
again
eat this toddy Acuras code blue on
paddles
chest compressions chest compressions
chest compressions before you shock so
when you shock you right away go back to
chest compression chest and Russian
strength compression all this time
without chest compressions is the blood
not circulating can someone do a chest
compressions or something he catch that
he goes all in he's sure he's one I call
I flip him Oh parka dayss I nailed his
ass
what did he get from that story my god
you got almost we're hiding oh oh the
Aces were high da tested for earn I'm
Chester disease alright I'm paused again
I'm looking up what ern I'm Chester is
because this is ridiculous
third I'm Chester disease it's a rare
type of slow growing blood cancer in
earn hime Chester the excess production
of histiocytes AKA histiocytosis leads
to inflammation that could damage organs
and tissues throughout the body causing
him to be thick and dense scarred
fibrotic and this tissue damage may lead
to organ failure
I thought they tested for this and if
they did a kidney biopsy they would have
found this I don't know where he's going
with this this is a disease that
probably happens one in a million kind
of appropriate for a house episode he
tested negative
so did Esther he's lied yeah the tumors
got it in for you Jesus don't lie fine
middle eye slope latest weed biopsy the
colon again reached the GI tract yet
it's there now this is liver his lungs
you want it to be there because then you
didn't screw up 12 years ago you can't
waste our one tests on the one disease
we know it's not
run the tip why didn't they do the
kidney biopsy take your time and say it
loud
they turn ready
cd68 positive so dramatic I feel like
start the treatment or this is how that
genetics United this is how the US
National Library of Medicine describes
it it's a rare type of slow-growing
blood cancer how is this child dying in
48 hours I don't know something about
this seems Shady how they just followed
regular protocol consulted the proper
physicians instead of ink instead of
having house run amok with this case
this would have been solved so much
quicker so much simpler without the
child suffering these side-effects
so Esther can rest peacefully oh yeah
house m.d. is awesome but check out
these hilarious 2 videos I know you're
gonna love them and stay happy and
healthy
[Music]